on a small island in russia stands a 300
year old multi-dome church that was
built entirely without nails
[Music]
kiss island is home to two wooden
churches
and an octagonal bell tower that
exemplify 18th century russian
architecture
the largest building on kaza island is
the church of the transfiguration
120 feet tall and covered in 22 domes
the church sparkles like silver when the
sun hits it
it was a tradition in russian carpentry
to build using only wooden logs with
interlocking corners and no nails or
steel reinforcement
the structure was sturdy enough to
survive until the 19th century when it
underwent restoration to return it to
its former glory
in 1990 the island was listed as a
unesco world heritage site and today the
island is a national open air museum
it might just be a legend but upon
completion of the structure it was said
kazai's main builder cast his axe into
the water and proclaimed
there was not and will not be another
one to match it
[Music]